okay guys in this problem the table
below gives us the rainfall recorded
from a number of rain gauges located
within and nearby a given catchment area
over a 6-hour period using the
arithmetic mean method find the average
precipitation in inches for the drainage
area and use it to determine the average
return interval of the storm event using
the provided return table the provided
return interval table so this problems
very easy we have to Simply sum
up the gauges
volumes and get the arithmetic
mean so we're going to do that
now + 3 +
1.2 +
0.9 plus
1.4 Plus
2 +
2.1 and all of this is divided by 11
sorry for the janky looking divisor
symbol anyway the answer to this is 1.
and the problem tells us to look at the
six hour period for the return interval
so if we look
at this precipitation frequency estimate
we can see that the duration of the
event is along the Y AIS here and we're
looking for the 6h hour period so that's
here so we will simply go over until we
find in this case it's right here
it's 1.83 is the volume of inches of
rain on average
to occur from this event from all the
rain gauges and we'll go up here to this
return interval so the answer here is
that this storm on average was a 2-year
return for the drainage
basin and that's all it takes to solve
this problem some of the other answers
given were for or if you weren't paying
close enough attention
and did the math right but came out with
either a different
day or the
wrong
duration or something like that so yeah
that's it for this problem